while she is a kid once I concluded I
would never be a professional athlete I
really wanted to be a veterinarian but
in the world I grew up in the highest
form of human endeavor was to be a
doctor my father was a radiologist and
so there was always this push to be a
doctor and so I entered a 6-year medical
program I finished high school and
finish my training pretty young and it
was only at the point at which i
finished my medical training that i
began to question whether or not that
was what i really wanted to do with the
rest of my life i didn't really know
frankly what i was going to do other
than I just didn't see medical practice
for the next 30 40 years as being where
I was headed one of my professors where
I went to medical school thought I might
like research and referred me to a
colleague of his at Rockefeller
University where I now work so I visited
her lab spent a year and decided I
really liked it and have stuck with it a
friend of mine once referred to me is
the accidental scientist which was
applied shortly after and Tyler wrote
the accidental tourist
you